We can save the day.
We will stand our ground.
We will be brave.
Brave.
Brave [again]
We will be heard.
We will matter.
Matter.
Matter [again]
Vote [6 times]
Nyeh
If you want to alienate almost anyone, no
matter their politics,
just say three little words:
Your friends will gasp, celebrities will judge
you,
your mother might still love you, but only
grudgingly.
Tell the world that you care about what happens
to it.
You have an obligation.
For America.
For America [repeated]
For America [tearing up]
Don't you care about America?
You not voting changes your life.
You are dishonoring your family.
If you don't vote, then you're an idiot.
Don't buy the guilt trip.
Not voting can be an equally legitimate and
moral choice.
Here are four of the most common myths used
to shame non voters.
We gotta stop thinking one vote.
We can't say one vote doesn't matter.
Your vote matters.
It effects everything.
First thing's first, you're not going to sway
a major election.
A single vote has decided precisely zero federal
races in US history.
And vanishingly few at the state level.
Voting is like playing the power ball,
punch your ticket or don't, your life is going
to stay the same.
The last presidential election turned on fewer
than a hundred thousand votes.
I know, but this is about you ans whether
or not you cast your one vote.
It simply won't effect the outcome, not if
you live in a swing state,
not if the electoral college were abolished,
not even if you're in Florida and your chad
is hung like a moose.
You can't complain if you didn't vote.
Well he's gonna suck, well you didn't do anything
about it.
Only about half the voting age population
makes it to the polls
and groups including young people, the poor
and the disabled
are underrepresented on voter rolls.
Do they not deserve a voice?
The act of voting does not a good citizen
make
and it's actually one of the least effective
ways
you can contribute to the American experiment.
Most social and cultural change happens outside
the political sphere
and that's a good thing.
Rather than follow the latest horse race,
you might spend your scarce time developing
a new vaccine,
exposing corruption or microwaving a burrito.
Any of these things can have a greater tangible
impact on the world than your vote.
I vote because it's all of our civic duty.
People died for that right.
I vote because I'm not a motherfucking communist.
Generations of brave Americans have fought
for your right to vote
and for your right not to.
In fact, you might choose not to vote because
you love your country.
Maybe you don't feel educated
or at least not enough to cancel out the vote
of your well informed neighbor.
That's ok and really quite moral.
Besides, even the most knowledgeable voters
can't predict what a candidate will do once
in office.
Look, a lot of our elected officials are uninformed.
Remember when Obama was going to reign in
W's foreign adventuring?
It was about 10 years and one drone kill list
ago.
They should just vote because it matters you
know.
Your employer can't tell you that you don't
have time.
Just get out and vote.
A principled citizen might actively avoid
a two party system
that systemically silences alternative voices.
You might decide that it doesn't represent
your interests by design.
That by voting for the lesser of two evils,
you're only helping the fat cats in Washington
maintain their smokescreen of legitimacy.
Why on earth wouldn't you want to vote?
I think voting is great, I just didn't care
this time
because it was between a giant douche and
a turd sandwich.
But Stan don't you know?
It's always between a giant douche and a turd
sandwich.
If that's the case, you should feel free to
wash your hands of the whole rotten mess.
At the end of the day, you might want to vote.
Maybe to give your grand-daughter an up close
look at the machinery of American government.
Maybe to get that fashion-forward sticker
selfie
that proves to all your instafriends how woke
or uncucked you are.
I'm afraid I'm turning out because I wanna
impress my friends.
Maybe you just really love middle school gyms.
So this Tuesday, go ahead and rock the vote
if it makes you happy.
But if you decide that it's a symbolic gesture
that's unlikely to tangibly help your family
or community,
it's ok to spend your time and resources doing
something more impactful.
This Tuesday, it's ok not to vote.